that would buy is two additional
fermenters we have three currently so
obviously about a 61% increase in our
capacity but we're also for the first
time adding strain on to that in line
forming so we'll take the fermented
protein and turn it straight into mince
or pieces or sausages etc whereas
previously we would have that a separate
factory so hence is a very big
investment for us and what about current
trading clearly you've experienced some
price hikes during the last 12 months
due to the weaker pound you know it
doesn't seem to have hit the bottom line
too much no in the short term the impact
of that is is neutral broadly to us so
we actually buy core quite a lot of
materials in dollars and particularly
euros but we also sell to the US and
into the eurozone so it's broadly flat
in terms of an impact hence the kind of
profit is not been materially hit by
that
what about UK consumers though are they
going to have to come to terms with
price hikes to in coming months well
we're not from Earth I mean one of the
things we're conscious of is it's
difficult for the retailers to pass on
price increases increasing it the moment
it's difficult for the consumers to cope
with price increases so we actually put
a lot of effort into actually avoiding
price increases by countering inflation
and a good example because is that we
invested in a combined heat and power
plant which cost us over 2 million
pounds which has just been installed but
that will reduce our energy costs by
about 3/4 of a million a year so it
constantly finding ways to counter the
inflation whether it's coming from
currency whether it's just coming from
the general inflation we're seeing now
may not be able to do that forever but
every year we can stave off inflation we
think that it's kind of good for the
consumer which then is good for our
business now clearly there's an awful
lot of speculation right now about the
shape of the brexit deal that the
government is going to obtain how how
would life change for you if the UK left
without a free trade deal and we fell
back on WTO terms would that be
particularly harmful to you well I mean
like any business it wouldn't be good
for us but clearly we're making a very
large investment both in the capacity
but also commercially to grow the
business at the high rates we're getting
so we're taking abuse
we continue to can continue to thrive
even with a hard version of brexit shall
we say part of the reason for that is
well we have significant sales in the EU
we have a lot of sales outside of the EU
the US the UK itself Australia as
examples and investing heavily in growth
in Asia at the moment which is small
because it's no but over the next three
to five years will be a very material
egg to our business so we can focus
where we grow depending on the outcomes
from from brexit so if the UK is able to
obtain free trade deals with countries
outside the EU quickly brexit could even
be a positive for you then well
ironically some of these areas it could
help us you know we actually have
tariffs going into the US Australia as
example certain parts of Asia so free
trade zones into some of those areas
would actually be helpful but I'd have
to say it would make it easier for the
business to thrive where they can with a
free market being available in the EU
there's no question about that
separately today you said you won't call
to be a billion pound brand a decade
from now that's a pretty big expansion
of the business when most big food
companies are seeing flats too
negligible growth yeah it is I mean we
believe in that we believe we can become
a billion dollars within ten years which
means growing at about 15 percent per
annum we're growing at about 19
currently and we somewhere in that
region for the end of this year but the
advantages for us compared to all the
food companies is our category is on
trend around the world kind of younger
more educated consumers are just cutting
down a little bit of meat so meat
alternatives are thriving we made the
best version of that in the world so
we're very competitive and with a
family-owned of the business in
modernist out of the Philippines they
can take a ten to fifteen year view of
the potential of that and invest
accordingly yes while growth is coming
through successful increases in
investment so it's not without its
challenges but we believe is eminently
possible for us and we're spending
hundred fifty million pounds to build
some of the capacity necessary to
achieve that